the first look at Will Smith as the
genie in Aladdin is live action film is
here yes guys in our childhood felt
freakin okay so Entertainment Weekly
released the first pics of the cast in
costume and the genie is not so blue at
least not yet yeah it's very different
from the 90s classic that we grew up
loving
so here's we'll dress to the nines as
genie and various shades of blue and a
bold hairdo and beard opposite Mina
Masood as Aladdin he also has a shirt
under his vest and fans are furious yeah
so there's no word though if CGI is
still involved in the film but it is a
drastic change from what we're used to
yeah and we know will took to Instagram
joking about that top notch ponytail and
he teased yes I'm gonna be blue last
month so we'll did open up to et about
his nerve-racking experience following
and Robin Williams footsteps is so
spectacular so there's such a beautiful
movie I just really I can't I can't wait
for people to say I was terrifying doing
the genie okay so we get that will is
trying to make this role his own which
is totally understandable but some
twitter users where wishing's gonna do
there there's something different so
this user even remade the e w cover
making will blue so I feel like we'll
probably see some blue in the movie and
this is just the first look but this
person tweeted out the cover writing
ruined one of our favorite Disney movies
in one picture and this one just said
thanks I hate it okay so I don't hate it
I understand I'm a die-hard Disney lover
I love all Disney movies but we haven't
seen the full movie yet well and here's
the thing Robin Williams version is so
iconic that really anything will did
what have been scrutinized in my opinion
on at least some oh absolutely yeah but
I am happy to hear that they're going in
a different direction because like you
said it is an iconic role no one will
ever replace Robins legacy but the whole
point of recreating it is to give it a
fresh spin on that 1992 films yeah I
think it's gonna be a major blockbuster
him no matter what it's such a beloved
movie we did dig up footage of Robin
Williams sharing how he brought his
original Genie character to life in this
old
from the 90s take a look we just throw
ideas and they just said try this and
then I said can I do and then sometimes
it gets a little blue and then but I'm a
genie so that's not bad you know we do
the other radio right now and they put
in stuff I can't believe that they yeah
but they do it because I think they have
a good time kind of pushing the
boundaries of Disney animation which is
great a whole generation is gonna go up
thinking you as a singer I think not
I think this to people going no man you
got no rhythm it's frightening they
should have the United Caucasian rhythm
fun you got no rhythm okay so the Disney
roll will never have a friend like Robin
but of course we like to give a little
will some room to prove himself
like I've said time and time again let's
not judge them yeah I totally agree with
you I cannot wait to see this movie and
really has will ever let us down yes no
no I love him he's my favorite but
really I'm hoping it's not this one it's
not gonna be this one no way but we will
have to wait until May 24th 2019 to see
how it all comes together on screen
right and in the meantime be sure to
subscribe to all things et until next
time let's keep chatting with each other
I'm at Kourtney underscore tezo know and
KD underscore Kraus bye for now
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]